thank you
[Music]
all right man since we have you here
today I think you'd be able to shed some
light on this whole thing hit me what's
going on with fousey man oh man
what's not going on with him why what's
going on with them I heard because he's
back and he's streaming though right cap
to recap very quickly
um for those of you for those of you who
don't know
um so he started doing live streams yeah
and was gaining like Mass attraction on
Twitch and then and then later on Kick
but like he came back yeah as a streamer
now yeah and apparently sober this time
yeah so here's here's a quick list of
like the timeline of infractions uh the
first thing he did that kind of went
viral outside of his own network was he
accidentally said the n-word while live
on stream because he was like rapping oh
he was out of the J Cole song he was
feeling it he was filming he was feeling
the Holy Spirit yeah and then uh but
that's kind of like maybe maybe not but
the reaction was well everybody the
reaction is why I went around yeah yeah
because I instantly upsetted himself and
started punching his bed and he goes I
never say that while still rapping
on the bridge I think for the musical
break
it was like streaming live at the
airport met this random drunk girl that
stumbled into the frame started talking
to her she ends up talking about how she
uh used to be sex trafficked and it was
got pretty heavy but then camera cuts
for a second he comes back and says that
him and her just had sex in the bathroom
um number three uh he was streaming
while walking down the freeway blocking
cars at night like he was just walking
along an actual freeway and uh that was
weird and then four he went over there
he's sober now yeah he's sober he's had
a couple bouts where he slapped other
creators like Jack Doherty and neon uh
and then number five is the big doozy
that's when he was uh in a hotel room
and this guy who's another streamer his
name's ganvil he claimed that he was
calling and harassing his family and
stuff
and then uh he told fousey that a girl
that he was seeing recently was really
just a plant sent from him and wasn't
real
and then um I'm real I just know that
motherfucker's not real that situation
and then uh fousey was threatening him
so gamble called the cops on him fousey
also called the cops on himself uh
because the he was trying to call the
cops on me I'm calling myself yeah he
was trying to report that this guy
gamble was threatening him and the and
the cops didn't seem like they were
gonna come so then fousey faked a
hostage situation and said he had a gun
to his head so the cops ended up coming
over and they ended up arresting him
because he's being irate and crazy dude
and he was recording all that in this
hotel room right I remember pieces of
that and then he actually got the the
cops just started not to charge him they
check him into a mental institution
instead didn't he get into like an
accident too while streaming or some
[__]
I'm sure
I think I think the whole thing is I
don't think he's sober
what was he what was he on yeah what is
he on because you've been friends with
him a long time does he seem like yeah
but even back then like I think he might
have been on something but I don't know
what it was but he was in definitely
more control and he knew it was more
about entertainment but now it just
seems like it's pure ego at this point
mixed with a little schizophrenia but I
think it's drugs I don't think I mean I
don't know if it's damn
you don't think it's Cuckoos I mean I
don't think we actually I don't think no
naturally he's not that way oh I think
he's just thought Drake was coming that
was kind of interesting I think after
that it went pretty wild I think the
dude like I mean I imagine like if your
first videos were like massively viral
and then you obviously they were fake
you're trying to do whatever it takes to
maintain some type of
uh I don't know viewership or like
self-acceptance I don't know what it is
but as soon as he came back and he was
bragging about how he was sober again no
one really I don't know that's a weird
brag but it wasn't like boat like humble
what was he on in the first place I
didn't know I have no idea so well I
didn't even know he had to get sober
I don't know but he made content
creators look probably even worse
I think there's something to do this
I just broke
he's saying that he broke her to do but
there's no confirmed like confirmation
about that but uh kid was like giving
hella people crazy ass deals but yeah
they are no they're giving those crazy
ass people both
they're also being scrutinized for uh
for not stopping this before it got what
are they supposed to do though they
don't give a [__] cut the stream
probably not I'm with Steve on that I
heard he was doing like a 24 7 stream
yeah so that's probably not good for
your brain right does he sleep because
you could sleep for eight hours
you yeah I guess you could that kind of
analysis
[Laughter]
not trip out as much underneath all the
like controversy that he's constantly
kicking up is boozy he's a decent guy
yeah he's a good he's a good dude I
think he's a really good actor
hmm what is that
what do you mean like you give him a
script and he can make them to life
nothing is genuine when you talk to him
no there was like There's so like during
his first depression times like we were
really close and he'd call myself and my
friend humble over like when he was
going through episodes and he was like
Hey I'm going through this episode with
myself right now and I wanted to make a
video about it and I just wanted you
guys here for support like emotional
support and mental sport like all right
cool so he came through and he was
talking to this film dude and he was
basically like uh we come up he's like
all right guys we're right with you let
me get this monologue off real quick he
goes are you ready he goes all right
action and he did this right away his
emotions went
that [__] is real and he does this whole
[__] perfect monologue and right when
he got done he goes
did you get it and then right then and
there I was like okay I don't know what
what this is because you went from being
really good in a good place to a perfect
like scripted thing that wasn't a script
I don't know what it was but right then
there I was like I don't know if we're
really helping you at this point anymore
or just being entertained that's why I
say he's a good actor because I I don't
know what is real even if our
relationship or a friendship was real or
what was because we've had a lot of
great talks off camera but I don't even
know if that was just
I I don't have no idea that one was the
one where I was like I'm a little scared
of this situation I think it's so dumb
if you could look into the camera right
now and say something to him what would
you say ah can you keep the music please
that sounds like Street jams that sounds
like B Street part two what is that I
don't know just cute music okay keep
more more uh r b piano piano like KC
Jojo
I don't know
Susie I don't know what's going on man
and if you're watching this I just want
you to know that uh dig deep Free
Yourself of your ego and just enjoy what
you have left
I don't know what this background music
is but I love I kind of like it but it
helps I think Roselle would be jealous
sounds very Asian
look at all the Chinese Harps dude quick
content
do you think there should be anything in
place to keep streamers from going too
far like should they always be rewarded
for the [__] they're pulling on streams
this is America dude Land of the Free
dude you putting up numbers Brother come
on but you know like even YouTube has
standards of what you can and can't do
it's kind of like shock porn you know
what he should do he should start doing
the NPC stuff those guys are just this
game it's all good ice cream it's all
good well it's dude Glizzy the Glizzy
attack guy yeah he went insanely viral
now dude I'm sure fousey could knock it
out the park the Glizzy robot guy
maximum tightness or whatever you see
that [__] what is the maximum no what
this is he's wearing like he's wearing
like a hot dog shoe I'm doing too much
all Steve day previews but they're
bleeding in dude give me tastes man The
Taste away but yeah but like you know
how uh every platform has guidelines
right but then um for kick it almost
seems like because that's the newer
platform and people are just going to be
so desperate to like get a leg up that
they're willing to do shock [__] like
Johnny Somalian [__] Japan like he's
back in Japan is he he has not learned
his lesson because he understands that
the more [__] gets kicked up the more
he's gonna get numbers but kick won't do
anything to stop it right that's the
model that's always happened yeah but
you can't do a lot of stuff on YouTube
you can't like even only fans girls
can't post photos they took in public
it's like yeah there's there's
stipulation you know that because I had
a studio and that's why they came to
shoot with me
put that in the title right like the
algorithm or like well like
de-prioritize you or something
yeah there's like something everything
has a game that you have to play but it
almost seems like because kick is newer
and they're trying to steal people over
they're like hey it's the wild west get
over here plus you probably gotta have
like three or four controversies
controversial moments in and like you're
still like oh and then you level out
yeah but well even with the
controversial [__] that's just hype you
know what I mean as long as somebody
isn't like getting killed you know what
I mean like actually in danger until
fousey and now that fousey's gone
obviously kid don't care and kick
continues on yeah and I didn't even
[__] know what
but like it took controversy for me to
learn about it yeah
yeah I'd probably like yeah we can we
can let somebody go crazy for a while
like and you're shipping then we'll kick
you off by the way they take the blame
fousey takes the blame yeah kick yeah
sure they take a little hit maybe image
wise but they just had a huge influx on
numbers they don't give a [__] and then
they're like all right now we'll make
one guideline well they they tweeted
free fousey
and then they deleted it
[Laughter]
yeah
lock up food so he's in a mental
institution right now right I think he's
being mentally assessed I don't know if
it's technically an institution he may
voluntarily be there
that's crazy just pivot to like mukbangs
or something
not for him because remember
um when he was so he was getting managed
by one of David's close friends from
back home
um and when he Abe yeah when he first
was doing YouTube Abe brought him down
here to show him this was maybe over 10
years ago right when he did the Drake
yeah like what YouTube could be and it's
just trying to show him like all the
like the little offices that are around
and people are kind of like building
their own like little companies and
stuff
so I remember that's the first fousey
I've ever met you know just someone else
oh man I love you guys I grew up on you
guys hopefully we could do you know like
a channel like yours one day and then I
saw him Skyrocket which is super cool
and then just to see like
like just the crazy like crash and burn
at the end has just been nuts yeah it's
been getting worse because he got in he
got in he got inspired by the wrong
group
yeah I think look I feel bad for Vermont
too like because he was I used to like
hate the fake prankers and stuff because
I was trying to do real pranks and blah
blah but I was I've once adpocalypse
happened I just kind of got grouped in
with all those guys anyway and I was
like yeah this sucks so like you know
and I can't imagine like I know Ed
apocalypse was was rough on me I can't
imagine what it was like for those guys
oh yeah a lot to lose like they were way
overextended like but basically had
houses that they could not afford to pay
for for one year for example in case of
emergency even so then also that's zero
now what are you gonna do and like all
these ad companies are dried up
everywhere so then I just feel awful for
those guys so you know I hope I wish him
well I really do I hope he gets help
[Music]